-You know our first guests
tonight from their work
as Olivia Benson and Elliot
Stabler on "Law & Order: SVU"
as well as the latest spin-off,
"Law & Order: Organized Crime."
You can see both shows
beginning Thursday nights
at 9:00 here on NBC.
Please welcome back to the show
Mariska Hargitay
and Christopher Meloni.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Welcome back, both of you!
[ Cheers and applause continue ]
-Wow!
-You say our names backstage
to announce us,
the crowd's reaction.
She turns to me, she goes,
"We've still got it."
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Well, and I should say.
I should say.
-We still got it.
-I think you --
I think you both
independently have it,
but I think
there's an extra excitement
that you're here together, so
thank you so much for making --
[ Cheers and applause ]
And I should also note,
you were --
this was planned a while ago.
There were some
scheduling issues
and you guys had to back out.
And you have such intense fans,
a lot of them took it out on me
on social media.
-No!
-They did.
It was as if, last minute,
I decided I didn't want you.
[ Laughter ]
-That's great, though.
This is perfectly us.
You go, "No!"
And I was thinking,
"Better you than me."
[ Laughter ]
Is this too casual, by the way?
-No, I think it's lovely.
-Not the dress but my posture.
-It's a little casual.
-Okay, great.
-What I wanted to say is
our fans are crazy, crazy loyal
and they're so nuts.
I don't think other people
have fans like we do.
I'm not ribbing on your fans.
I'm sure they're great.
I'm just saying the "SVU" fans
are -- They're hard-core.
-And you know, there's a very --
[ Cheers and applause ]
There's the thinnest of veneer
between you and your fans
when you film a show
that is often outdoors
in New York City, right?
-Oh, yeah.
-You see fans a lot.
They feel very close to you.
They have made art
based on you guys.
-They have made art.
-A beautiful mug, Christopher.
You sent us a picture.
Can I show this?
And I mean,
just to get the likeness right
on a mug like this.
-It's not easy.
-I mean, it is --
[ Laughter ]
I mean, when you...
-Spit in it.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-I've had that for 20 years.
-Have you really?
-Yeah.
-'Cause it looks like it just
came out of the box.
-I know.
[ Laughter ]
Right out of the kiln.
-Right out of the kiln.
And look at that.
That's really nice, too,
'cause you do have such
a beautiful profile.
-And a strong chin.
-Strong chin.
-Big nose, strong chin.
-That's like a double shot
of espresso when you have that
in the morning.
-Every morning.
-Yeah.
Also, people have referenced,
when the two of you
are together, and again this
is just on my social media,
Chriska or Chrishka.
-It's Chrishka.
-Chrishka, thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's Chrishka.
Oh, yeah, we're Chrishka.
-That's really nice.
-Yeah, it's beautiful.
-Or Bensler.
-Bensler. Is it Bensler?
-Yeah.
-Chrishka and Bensler.
-Oh, Bensler and Chrishka.
Okay, great.
-There was a new one
that just happened.
Oh, Marshmelon.
-Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Marshmallow?
-Chris calls me Marsha
sometimes.
-Gotcha.
-One of the many names.
-Now, last time you were here,
you were here with Ice-T.
Did you want to
come out to prove
that you guys have
better chemistry?
-No.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
I want to --
Alright, so, the show, 23 years.
-Wait, I want to show what
my fans did for me.
-What did they do?
[ Laughter ]
-Did you bring it?
-Yes, I did.
-"But what about me?"
-Oh, yeah, they did. I'm sorry.
-Yeah, because look.
-Okay, I apologize.
-So, there's three.
-Okay.
-Guys?
[ Audience awws ]
Come on, all I ever wanted.
-They're voodoo dolls.
[ Laughter ]
-All I ever wanted was a doll
named after me.
-I think we only have two.
-No, there's three.
Just saying, if you didn't --
-He wants to keep one.
-My fans are gonna be so mad
that you didn't have the third.
-This is all I have down there.
-How about this?
And look at the hair. Whoo!
-If there's one backstage,
we'll have it
'cause we'll do two acts
with you guys.
So if we find the third one,
we'll bring it out.
But I will be honest. Can I just
say something, Mariska?
Don't take it the wrong way.
If it looks just like these two,
I don't know
if we needed to show it.
[ Laughter ]
-I hear you, but the other one
was the first one.
It's a frownie face doll.
-Okay, gotcha, alright.
Alright. So I want to ask,
you had done --
I knew you first from "Oz."
You had done a couple episodes
of "E.R."
When you read
the pilot for "SVU,"
what were your first reactions
to it?
-It was called "Sex Crimes."
-Yeah, I remember.
-I literally went, "Okay,"
as did my mother because once --
because when we got it, when we
screen-tested and we got it,
I go, "Mom, I got it."
"You got what?"
"I'm on 'Sex Crimes.'"
[ Laughter ]
She's like,
"Can they change the name?"
-Did you have to say,
"Trying to catch them;
I play one of the guys
trying to catch them"?
[ Laughter ]
-Exactly, yeah.
"I'm the good guy."
-And then she called Dick,
and he did change the name.
-Exactly.
-Did it ever air
as "Sex Crimes"?
-No, no, no.
-Never? Okay, gotcha.
-We were actually beginning to
do a little publicity for it,
and one of the publicists
ran up to us --
We're doing
whatever publicity line.
-Yeah.
-And I said, you know,
"It's great to be working on
the new show 'Sex Crimes.'"
And she came running up,
"Hey, don't ever say
those words again!"
[ Laughter ]
"SVU."
-Nobody will watch a show called
"Sex Crimes."
-So, "Law & Order" is obviously
a franchise at this point,
so you know that it has
a certain weight to be
auditioning for
a Dick Wolf show.
Do you remember being nervous
at the time like,
"Oh, this could be --" I mean,
no one thinks this could be
a show that is on
for 20-plus years.
But did you think,
"Oh, this might be actual --
you know, it's kind of
a normal job"?
-Well, yeah, I thought --
You never think,
after being a struggling actor
for so long,
that any show is going to go.
-Right.
-But this was a unique audition
for us because when we met,
there was a certain chemistry,
so I actually wasn't nervous
at the audition.
But you never think what
happened would happen.
You can't -- You can't dream it,
quite frankly.
-Do you want to re-enact
how that happened?
-Yeah.
-If you do.
-Sure, go ahead.
What's the best camera?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Is this good?
-This is real.
This is what happened.
You ready?
Alright, ready?
-So, I open the door to the
audition, and I go like this.
-Slattery!
-Meloni!
-And it was that.
[ Audience awws ]
-Wow.
-I had heard that John Slattery
was testing for the part.
-The guy who did "Mad Men."
-And I was so excited.
Never met him.
-Yeah.
-And he comes in, and so I knew
the other two guys,
so I knew that
they weren't Slattery.
And I see him and I go,
"Slattery,"
and he just goes, "Meloni!"
-Wow.
[ Laughter ]
I know Slattery,
and it's a big whiff to think --
-It's a different guy, right?
-Real different guy.
It's not like you're ever like,
"Those two,
you can't tell those two apart,"
because you definitely can.
[ Laughter ]
-And yet Slattery and I would
have been great together.
Right?
-I hate to spend today making it
about that, but you guys would
have been great together.
-Whatever.
[ Laughter ]
-Noooo!
-No, no, no, no, no.
We're so happy it ended up
this way.
I have so much more to ask.
-It was in the cards.
-We will be right back with more
from Mariska Hargitay
and Christopher Meloni.